i'm joined now from moscow by alexander
salafiaf chair of the open russia
movement and a friend
of alexey navalny hello good afternoon
thank you for your time
today first of all i wonder if you could
update us on mr navalny's condition
well unfortunately there are no updates
he's stable but he's really bad
so uh but thanks god he's he's not in
moscow anymore
uh the authority is finally
let uh to transport him to berlin uh
but that was a that was a problem of
course too just to transport him uh
because
it seems the authorities were trying to
hide all the evidences and to make all
the toxin
go out is go out from his body in order
to make it
difficult to understand what was the
toxic what was the kind of the toxic
in his blood and of course this isn't
the first time he has been
treated in hospital is it it's not the
first time it
has already happened last year during
the elections
uh he was um uh well we suspect he was
uh
poisoned during his arrest uh his 30-day
arrest or even more
when we all i mean all of the candidates
who
running the campaign last summer we all
were arrested but something happened to
him
and of course the authorities again
claimed it was just an allergic
reaction yeah russian doctors had said
prior to his being taken to berlin that
there were no signs of toxin
in his body so what suggests to you
there are of course definitely that was
a
an attempt of political assassination
and it happened
not the first time with the opposition
figures and journalists
for instance a very close friend of mine
vladimir karamoza a couple of years ago
was
poisoned and everything happened the
same way
so it happened just uh a few hours prior
to the flight
because in the flight during the flight
is much more difficult to help
someone who is who's been poisoned
uh so there are more chances that the
person is gonna die
and uh he felt the same way he was
literally screaming because
all of his body was aching so much he
was trying to chew his own
lips just to distract his attention from
that
from that pain to some other pain and he
told me that everything happened the
same way as
with alexey navalny and pyotr versus was
poisoned same way
even anna politkovsky in 2003 it
happened
all the same way well if
this uh keeps on happening isn't it
perhaps time for for the critics to
to fall in line excuse me
if this is happening uh more and more as
you suggest
uh people are targeted should these uh
prominent critics of president putin
perhaps uh fall in line now and uh be
more silent
i guess that is what you'll allege the
kremlin wants
the kremlin definitely wants everyone to
be silent that's that's obvious and uh
moreover i think
somehow it is connected with the uh with
the
uh situation happening now in belarus
they
see probably that uh um
you need to eliminate all the possible
leaders of the protest
so that the masses do not protest in
russia as well as they do in minsk right
now
yeah talk to us about um russia's
involvement
in what's going on in belarus um
alexander lukashenko had suggested that
russia might become
involved and have some troops coming in
to try to restore order is that likely
to happen
and what kind of sway has president
putin got and what happens in belarus
well officially we do not
have any troops right now in belarus but
according to some rumors and
a lot of photos being posted on twitter
on different social media
there are a lot of troops being
transported
in the way uh to belarus so we do not
know
probably they are already there but just
wearing
the belarus uniform probably so it's
well we speak same language so it's
quite difficult to uh to make a
difference between
russian and battle russian so uh
well as i have already mentioned we have
a lot of evidences that
a lot of troops are being transported in
the direction of belarus
and we've obviously seen this huge
uprising on the streets independence
square in
minsk which is is growing today two
weeks after uh
the election uh scenes that have been
repeated over the world in
in past years will will they have any
effect or can they if they continue
their strike
they have uh good chances to to
for the success in this story if they
just keep
going into the streets protesting i
think
not because it seems that russia has
already sent a lot of
uh media technologists and not only
media political technologists to
uh political advisors to belarus it
seems they are now using the same tactic
as
russian authorities are implementing in
khabarovsk for instance
so they are basically uh giving people
the opportunity to go to protest okay
all right
and then a month two months happen uh
pass
and then they just start initiating
criminal cases and putting people into
jail one by one
so i'm afraid if uh fellow russian
people will stop their strikes
they will have the same scenario as
right now happens in in russia
and what's the relationship like
personally between the two presidents
lukashenko
and putin once again what's what's
what's
what what's the relationship like
between the two leaders
uh well actually the relations are quite
tight
so i can't say they like each other uh
basically
all we all know that they practically
hate each other
but being too tyrants and being two
dictators of course they have more in
common uh
of course they uh well at least
officially they say we will help each
other
and um uh you know but still
we had some different moments with luka
shankar because he
pretty much likes the anti-russia
uh stylistic in his speech so he
always scares his own people that
russia can come up if not me then russia
will come up and just
annex belarus and we will just be the
part of russia and do you want this of
course you're not
and so he likes this rhetoric pretty
much
but still being authoritarian dictators
i mean of course they will help each
other
all right so we'll leave it there
alexander solafief
joining us from moscow thank you very
much indeed for your thoughts this
afternoon